emotionally charged trial of three white
men accused of murdering ahmad arbury
last year is underway in brunswick
georgia on friday prosecutors showed
video of the men using their trucks to
chase down and eventually confront the
black jogger defense attorneys countered
that their clients acted in self-defense
believing that arbory posed a threat to
the neighborhood amar villafanca reports
wanda cooper jones sobbed in the
courtroom look how far mr arbory is for
the first time she watched the video
that showed her son ahmad arbury being
chased shot and killed
the now infamous video was part of the
prosecution's opening statements in the
murder trial of travis and gregory
mcmichael and william roddy bryant
prosecutors say the mcmichaels assumed
the worst when they spotted arbory
walking out of an open construction site
while jogging in the neighborhood all
three of these defendants
did everything they did
based on
assumptions and they made decisions
in their driveways
based on those assumptions
that took
a young man's life
jurors also saw graphic body camera
video from the day arbory was killed
recorded by a glenn county police
officer it's their duty
and responsibility to each other
to protect each other defense attorneys
explained their side describing the
mcmichaels as watching out for fellow
residents after a series of break-ins
and burglaries in the neighborhood and
calling arbury the aggressor during the
final confrontation it's tragic that
ahmad arby lost his life
but at that point
travis mcmichael is acting in self
defense
after the long day in court arbory's
family addressed the media today i
decided it was time to see the video
it's very heartbreaking
but
i've got past that part
an emotional first day and the jury will
hear from more witnesses when the trial
continues on monday for cbs saturday
morning omar villafranca brunswick
georgia